so in the world of work it's the week of
trailers is like trailer week 2016
ourselves a trailer for war for the
Planet of the Apes
it looks cool dude like these Apes
movies are crushing here Caesar all like
I didn't want this war go
Caesar is Snoke the new theory coming
this Monday when they're on the beach
man they're riding their horses that's
some of the best CGI ever in cinema oh
my god this kind of CGI you look at
you're like there's no excuse for shitty
CGI anymore we're that good now those
Apes movies look better and better and
this is it Matt the end of dawn of the
Planet of the Apes does the whole thing
we lose the armies coming so now the
army is here
led by Woody Harrelson who was one
intense dude when he wants to be and
he's the one he's making his last and
even says in this trailer he's like if
we fail it will be a planet of age and
it was really thinking about disease
Apes movies it really isn't on one side
as to how this all went down there is
conflict happening like this is gonna
change the shape of the world there will
be a new species running everything how
did we get here what side did it really
both did and I find that fascinating
it's not on one side it's not all like
well humanity just through selfish they
can't share the apes should have it you
remember Koba and the last one he was a
dick and he started a lot of this
now
you feel like maybe they could still
work it out they're not going to man
they're talking with guns on this one
and there's one shot that actually makes
me it gets me curious in theorizing what
does that shot mean you have a
helicopter shooting dudes
so our Apes flying helicopters is that a
on the side of the humans is that a
captive of the humans in which case our
Apes flying helicopters you thought apes
on horses was impressive holy apes
in choppers is that a thing or are there
apes in humans on both sides who shared
the perspective of both sides
I don't know love some of the scenery
man it looks like the ape village or at
least Cesar's pad is behind this
waterfall and you just see shadows of
humans coming down it and see just like
what the hell is that ads Woody
Harrelson come on direct some after
that last move man humans do like we're
going to do this that we're going to
eradicate the Apes and Caesar is again
in a tough spot he's like I didn't want
the war before I didn't want to be this
later and I keep getting shuffled
and I have to deal with that and
just now I got a fight but again seems
like a really cool leader type is like I
showed you mercy and now you
pay me with war so we're going to war I
guess we all know how this is going to
go down because there's a movie with
Charlton Heston spoilers like the rug
won for Apes it's a last stand you know
how it's gonna go down you know the
outcome because there is a movie that
came out decades ago that shows us but
these Apes movies have got their
together remember when Rise of the
Planet of the Apes a trailer came at I
was like oh yeah sure did fell in that
gun of whatever and now if this movie
lands if war for the Planet of the Apes
is actually great that's a solid trilogy
right there man that's a good time to be
alive but I hope this movie executed
well man cuz my one thing about Planet
of the Apes I've always been like how on
earth did the Apes take over I know
they're much stronger than people so if
it was a fistfight I would get them
winning we have tanks we have choppers
we have planes we have rockets we have
bazookas we have more machinery have
more artillery a virus wiping had a lot
of mankind that was a good first step
but even then I was like I feel like we
could scrape out of that I feel like
this movie if it fills in that gap
properly and I walked out going holy
that's exactly how and I buy it I
am down for this I'm looking forward to
this man so war for the Planet of the
Apes the first trailer have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know that
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to say more
[Music]